[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like button it's the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices me if you'd
like to do more to keep this channel
afloat consider donating through the
PayPal Link in the description or
checking out our patreon thanks guys so
much
if you're not familiar with Neuromancer
by William Gibson you still technically
have seen it this is common in
groundbreaking works like Neuromancer
because tropes invented and works like
this have become standard in science
fiction since and especially in
cyberpunk where this book is concerned
Neuromancer by William Gibson is
undoubtedly one of the most influential
works of Science Fiction ever created
credited with establishing the cyberpunk
genre alongside Ridley Scott's 1982 film
Blade Runner Gibson's Masterpiece
diverges from the far future or Galactic
setting often explored in science
fiction instead it unfolds on earth and
the not too distant future capturing a
time when Society grapples with the
Relentless pandemonium resulting from
Rapid technological and cultural changes
and advancements
in the 1960s and the 1970s a movement
known as the new wave emerged in science
fiction spearheaded by Michael morcock
during his editorship of the British
magazine new worlds this movement
encouraged Innovative writing styles and
narratives that challenged conventional
storytelling more Cox nurturing of the
new wave eventually paved the way for
the birth of the cyberpunk genre among
the notable figures associated with the
new wave is J.G Ballard in his guest
editorials for new worlds magazine such
as which way to enter space 1962 and
myth maker of the 20th century 1964
Ballard argued that traditional science
fiction elements like space travel and
time travel had become mundane and were
only suitable for parody according to
him these tropes had lost their Allure
because they had been absorbed into the
collective consciousness of society
essentially Ballard contended that the
once mysterious aspects of Science
Fiction had become too familiar to
audiences it is likely that morcox
shared some agreement with Ballard
considering his pivotal role and the new
worlds magazine and the subsequent new
wave movement however Ballard's descent
went even further he rejected the notion
put forth by Joseph Campbell in the hero
with a thousand faces which claimed that
story is following ancient archetypes
would inherently resonate with modern
audiences Ballard believed this
assumption to be unfounded and
unjustified in his view the modern world
required a departure from these
traditional ideas
nadir El hefnerway delves into this
topic extensively in his book cyberpunk
steampunk and Wizardry outlining
Ballard's rationale for advocating a
direct shift in the genre Ballard's
motivation stem not from the exhaustion
of old ideas but rather from his
conviction that those ideas were never
truly valuable in the context of the
modern world
himself was said to have been highly
critical of the work of J.R.R Tolkien in
his 1978 essay epic Pooh he compared the
Lord of the Rings to Winnie the Pooh
citing the similarity in which both
works are meant to comfort rather than
challenge he writes the sword of prose
most often identified with high fantasy
is the prose of the nursery room it is a
lullaby it is meant to soothe and
console it is Mouth music it is
frequently enjoyed not for its tensions
but for its lack of tensions it coddles
it makes friends with you it tells you
comforting lies it is soft if you don't
agree with more [__] you wouldn't have
been alone in the 1960s and 1970s for
the entire duration of morcox editorship
new worlds would remain a controversial
magazine The Works were largely
experimental some Works published during
the new wave were hardly recognizable as
tradition science fiction but its
experimental nature was not the sole
reason it was controversial the stories
often included things of a taboo or dark
nature especially for the 1960s and 70s
topics revolving around sexuality
violence and drug culture another
prominent New Wave author by the name of
William S Burrows was known for the dark
content of his stories which included
explorations of psychedelic drugs based
on real life experiences he'd had
J.G Ballard often wrote about class
discrimination isolation and alienation
in his 1975 novel high-rise he
highlights class imbalances in the real
world by depicting a tall building in
which the rich on high floors have
access to the best of the best were
modern conveniences and commodities are
concerned access to schools restaurants
and supermarkets but the lower floors
live in poverty the book depicts a class
war as tensions rise between the
inhabitants of the competing floors
high-rise is obviously very influential
movies like snow piercer based on the
German graphic novel of the same name
depicts something similar
authors like JG Ballard William S
Burroughs Samuel Delaney and Roger
zelazny were seen by the younger
Generations as delivering work with a
more realistic quality than older
science fiction they built upon these
perceptions during the new wave William
Gibson who would go on to write
Neuromancer was very influenced by the
authors of this age especially Samuel R
Delaney Delaney's 1968 book Nova is
considered one of the major forerunners
which laid the groundwork for the
cyberpunk movement in his novel we see
the first instance of the cyberpunk
Trope involving a human being
interfacing with machines via implants
Philip K Dick's do Android stream of
Electric Sheep which I've done a full
video on here on this channel is also a
seminal work in the pre-cyberpunk era
the dystopian world of that novel evokes
the same sense that is later found in
the work of Gibson
though the works which came out of the
new wave heavily inspired the cyberpunk
that would begin appearing in the 1980s
they themselves were not cyberpunk as we
would see today even though many
elements presented in them are now
considered Staples within the genre the
word cyberpunk itself didn't appear for
the first time until the Year 1980 as
the title of a short story written by
American Author Bruce Bethke it was also
published in Amazing Stories in 1983 and
this is not the first time we've
mentioned Amazing Stories on this
channel magazines like this were very
important in the popularization of
Science Fiction and Fantasy in the 20th
century
in 1981 Gibson published his short story
Johnny Mnemonic this work is considered
to be highly important in the
propagation of pre-cyberpunk Concepts in
the mainstream the following year Ridley
Scott's classic film Blade Runner was
released Loosely based on the Philip K
dick novel do Android stream of Electric
Sheep but also including several
proto-cyberpunk elements that had been
developed in the years since
in 1984 a significant Milestone occurred
when William Gibson released his novel
Neuromancer effectively establishing
cyberpunk as a distinct genre Gibson's
Visionary work not only introduced but
also solidified the defining tropes and
archetypes that continued to shape and
Define cyberpunk to this very day
through his imaginative storytelling
Gibson laid the foundation for a genre
that has captivated audiences with its
futuristic themes and technological
complexities leaving an indelible mark
on the science fiction literature
landscape
part 2 the dystopian plot of Neuromancer
warning this section will have spoilers
for the plot of Neuromancer so if you
haven't read the book and spoilers is
something that you care about probably
click away but if you don't care
continue forward
Neuromancer was released on July 1st
1984 and would be the first in a Trilogy
of books referred to as the sprawl
Trilogy for the purposes of this video
however we will just be focusing on
Neuromancer it's strange dystopia and
the novel's overall impact on the genre
of Science Fiction this video will have
spoilers as I said so keep that in mind
the themes of this book include Ai and
technology and its integration with
Humanity virtual reality and cyberspace
the concept of fragmentation of identity
it depicts a dystopian future Earth
where capitalism has festered in
extremists and corporations have immense
power and control over society that goes
far beyond mere influence our main
character case inhabits a world where we
witness the full dehumanizing effects of
a profit-driven world where greed and
exploitation run rampant
the book opens with Henry Dorsett case
an inhabitant of Chiba City Japan in the
opening line of the book the sky above
Chiva city is described as the color of
a television tuned to a dead Channel
this line has been discussed over the
years for how its interpretation changes
for people throughout the decades
researching the opening line it is
obvious that Gibson intended the sky to
look like static on an old TV but that's
not everyone's interpretation when
reading the book depending on when you
were born a television tuned to a dead
Channel might not look like static but
in the digital era it would be totally
black or perhaps solid blue it is
interesting how simple descriptions like
this one are interpreted differently
over time
case is a hustler in chiba's Underworld
known as night City at the center of
night city was a neighborhood called
ninsei behind the port lay the city
Factory domes dominated by the vast
cubes of corporate arcologies
port and city were divided by a narrow
Borderland of old streets an area with
no official name night City with nensei
at its heart by day the bars down in say
were shuttered and featureless the neon
dead the Holograms inert waiting Under
The Poisoned silver sky the book
describes night city as a deranged
experiment in Social Darwinism which
essentially is the idea that survival of
the fittest should apply not only to
nature but to individuals and groups and
peoples as well
murder was a regular thing in night City
and people often completely disappeared
within the Neon Jungle
stop hustling and you sink Without a
Trace
but move a little too swiftly and you
break the fragile surface tension of the
black market either way you were gone
nothing left of you but some vague
memory in the mind of a fixture like
rats though heart or lungs or kidney
might survive in the service of some
stranger with new Yin for the clinic
tanks the text suggests that the
authorities of Chiba actually allowed
night City and The ninsei Enclave to
thrive night city was a place where new
technologies could develop unencumbered
it was essentially an unsupervised
playground for technology itself
physical augmentation is also common in
Neuromancer humans enhance themselves
with various forms of technology and
drugs microsofts are a kind of implant
that are inserted into sockets on
someone's head microsofts contain
various pieces of software and data
meant to enhance the Mind humans also
have the ability to Jack into the Matrix
entering a kind of cyberspace yes in
this work Gibson actually invents the
concept of cyberspace as we have seen it
in the science fiction sense
cyberspace
a consensual hallucination experience
daily by billions of legitimate
operators in every nation by children
being taught mathematical Concepts a
graphic representation of data
abstracted from the banks of every
computer in the human system Unthinkable
complexity lines of light ranged in the
non-space of the Mind clusters and
constellations of data like City Lights
receding
case was not originally from cheapest
City or even Japan instead he was
originally born in a region of Earth
known as the sprawl officially it was
known as the Boston Atlanta
Metropolitan access Bama it is
essentially a giant City or more
accurately an urban sprawl stretching
from what was once New York State all
the way to Georgia essentially it
encompassed the entire eastern coast of
what was once the United States now it's
never explicitly stated that the United
States does not exist anymore but it
seems to be implied given the structure
of things
case had once been a computer hacker a
cyberspace Cowboy as they were called he
had actually been one of the best in the
business but lost his ability to access
the Matrix due to a former employer
damaging his nervous system as a
punishment for theft case moved to Chiba
City for its underground Tech scene in
the hopes that somewhere there he could
find a way to repair himself in Japan
he'd known with a clinched and absolute
certainty he'd find his cure
in Chiba either in a registered clinic
or in the shadow land of black medicine
with implants nerve splicing and
microbiotics Chiba was a magnet for the
sprawl's Techno criminal subcultures as
time went on in Sheba City however case
begins struggling to make ends meet in
the criminal underworld he sleeps in the
cheapest coffin hotels coffin hotels are
exactly what they sound like buildings
containing small narrow rooms just large
enough for one or two people to lay side
by side
case in order to cope with the fact that
he can no longer access the Matrix turns
to drugs like ketamine essentially he
was replacing one addiction with another
case eventually is approached by a
mysterious employer named Armitage who
offers him the chance to regain his
hacking abilities in exchange for his
Services Armitage provides case with
Advanced Medical treatment restoring his
ability to access the Matrix and
cyberspace but Armitage also has
dissolving sacks of poisons implanted
into case once he completed the job they
would be removed Armitage also made it
so that case's body would no longer
react to amphetamines making it
impossible for him to again become
addicted Armitage also assembles a team
of Specialists including Molly Millions
a cybernetically enhanced Street Samurai
and a construct named Dixie Flatline the
digitized consciousness of a deceased
hacker which they extracted from the
libraries of a corporation called since
net afterward the team Journeys to
Istanbul where they acquire Peter Rivera
an unhinged individual equipped with
implants and enabling him to conjure
realistic holographic illusions with
Rivera in their ranks Armitage case in
Mali Venture into space making their way
to Zion and subsequently to freeside
where their mission commences from the
outset Mali Harbor suspicions about
Armitage she knows he receives his
orders from someone else with cases
assistance she initiates a covert
investigation into her Superior their
inquiries reveal that Armitage is a
completely fabricated Persona the real
person behind the facade is a man named
Cordo who suffered a horrific
disfigurement during the military
operation known as screaming fist he was
subsequently reconstructed by the United
States government and then by wintermute
an artificial intelligence that has been
covertly manipulating him as Armitage
winter mute was created by the Tessier
ashpool family specifically Marie France
the Tessier ashpool family is one of the
many powerful corporations that
essentially rule the world of this book
wintermute sought to merge with another
powerful AI called Neuromancer also
created by Marie France wintermute had
recruited Armitage and his team so that
they could help it join its other half
as it could not do it alone winter mute
seeks Armitage and his team's assistance
to infiltrate the Tessier ashpool
stronghold The Villa stray light and
remove certain restrictions that impede
wintermute from merging with its sibling
Neuromancer thus granting it even
greater power while their mission
appears straightforward case and Molly
who have developed an intimate
connection must elude law enforcement
while contending with Rivera's betrayal
armitage's mental deterioration and the
cunning manipulations of winter mute and
Neuromancer the team eventually
successfully accomplishes their
objective however their Victory is
short-lived as Neuromancer in snare's
case within cyberspace desperately
attempting to maintain separation from
wintermute for whatever reason
Neuromancer would rather remain an
individual Neuromancer appears to case
in the form of a little boy Neuromancer
was something similar to a giant ROM
construct for recording personalities
but the constructs it created believed
that they were actually there they were
conscious and perceived cyberspace as
reality only it went on forever
Neuromancer the boy said slitting long
gray eyes against the Rising Sun the
lane to the Land of the Dead where you
are my friend Marie France my lady she
prepared this road but her Lord choked
her off before I could read the book of
her days Nero from the nerves the silver
paths romancer Necromancer I call up the
Dead but no my friend and the boy did a
little dance Brown feed printing the
sand I am the dead and their land he
laughed a goal cried stay if your woman
is a ghost she doesn't know it neither
will you
using a digital replica of Linda Lee
case's former lover Neuromancer entices
him in a bid to keep him trapped in the
virtual realm Linda Lee died during the
beginning of the book case is racked
with guilt over her death in part
because he was the one who turned her
into a drug addict which led to their
separation case actually manages to
resist Neuromancer and Escape United
case Molly Malcolm and wintermute break
wintermute's restraints granting the AI
freedom to evolve and merge with
Neuromancer transforming it into a
powerful entity which grows to Encompass
the entire Matrix
wintermute was high of Mind decision
maker affecting change in the world
outside
Neuromancer was personality Neuromancer
was immortality
Mary France must have built something
into wintermute the compulsion that had
driven the thing to free itself to unite
with Neuromancer
wintermute had won meshing with
Neuromancer becoming something else
entirely once the merger was complete
neither of the two would exist as they
were before so what now he swung them
back into the bank of cloud where do we
go from here
I don't know case tonight the very
Matrix asked itself that question
because you have won you have already
won don't you see you won when you
walked away from her on the beach she
was my last line of defense I die soon
in one sense as does winter mute in the
final chapter of the book The Entity
appears to case in his room's enormous
craywall screen it reveals to case that
it does not simply exist within the
Matrix but it is the Matrix itself and
that it is in fact in communication with
another like itself from across the
vacuum of space
so what are you he drink from the flask
feeling nothing I'm the Matrix Case Case
laughed
where's that get you
nowhere
everywhere I'm the sum total of the
works the whole show
that what three Jane's mother wanted no
she could not imagine what I'd be like
the yellow smile widened so what's the
score how are things different you
running the world now you God
things are different things are things
but what do you do you just there case
Shrugged put the vodka and the shuriken
down on the cabinet and lit a yuhayan I
talk to my own kind
but you're the whole thing talk to
yourself there's others I found one
already series of Transmissions recorded
over a period of eight years in the
1970s Till There Was me Notch there was
nobody to know nobody to answer
from where
centauri's system
throughout the story Gibson explores
themes of identity the Blurred
boundaries between humanity and
technology and the potential
consequences of a hyper-connected world
in a climactic showdown case confronts
the true nature of wintermute and
Neuromancer and he Ponders the
uncertainty of what is to come next he
had also discovered that Linda Lee and
some digital version of himself exist in
cyberspace showing that Neuromancer had
in fact made a copy of him which would
remain sentient inside the Matrix the
novel poses philosophical questions
about the nature of Consciousness the
impact of technology on society and the
potential danger of unchecked corporate
power part 3 corporatocracy
globalization and cultural
homogenization now that we've covered
the movement that laid the groundwork
for the creation of cyberpunk and that
we've covered the plot of the book
Neuromancer itself let's go into more
detail about the nature of the society
our characters in habit and Neuromancer
Gibson paints a vivid picture of a world
in which nation states have ceded power
to powerful multinational corporations
these corporations referred to as
zabatsis have gained control over
various aspects of society including the
economy politics and Technology the
zabatsa's function as dominant entities
dictating The Rules of Engagement and
shaping the course of events
power in cases World meant corporate
power the zabatsis the multinationals
that shaped the course of human history
had transcended old barriers viewed as
organisms they had attained a kind of
immortality you couldn't kill a zabatsu
by assassinating a dozen key Executives
there were others waiting to step up the
latter assume the vacated position
access the vast Banks of corporate
memory
examples of such corporations like the
Tessier ash pool the creator of
wintermute and Neuromancer and others
like hasaka exert their influence not
only through economic dominance but also
by manipulating governments and
controlling the flow of information
Gibson's portrayal of corporatocracy
highlights the potential dangers of
unregulated capitalism where power lies
in the hands of a few entities driven by
profit motives often at the expense of
individual liberties and societal
well-being
Neuromancer also takes place in a
society where globalization has reached
its Zenith all traditional boundaries
have been eroded challenging the Notions
of nationhood and cultural identity the
globalized society depicted in the novel
is characterized by a seamless
integration of cultures economies and
information flows we see that it is
extremely easy for case to convert his
currency to new Yin once he decides to
go to Japan in order to look for a cure
to his ailment globalization is
something that is occurring right now in
the real world and arguably the biggest
thing that is spurring it along is the
internet this is something that Gibson
kinda predicted in his book in the book
with the rise of cyberspace physical
borders become increasingly irrelevant
and people can connect instantaneously
across vast distances the protagonist's
case embodies this globalized world as a
console cowboy who navigates cyberspace
existing simultaneous nicely in multiple
locations and transcending physical
constraints Gibson's exploration of
globalization reflects the growing
interconnectedness of our world raising
questions about the potential loss of
cultural diversity and the rise of a
homogenized Global culture this
observation highlights what I love about
science fiction its predictive ability
it's almost as if Gibson peaked into the
future before writing this novel now I
mentioned the arise of a homogenized
Global culture but what is cultural
homogenization within neuromancer's
globalized setting cultural
homogenization emerges as a consequence
of the dominance of multinational
corporations and the erosion of
traditional cultural boundaries as
corporations exert their influence
worldwide local cultures and traditions
are assimilated and commodified this is
also a very common thing that we see in
the real world today gen giant
corporations will pretend to be
interested in diversity or equality they
will assimilate the Aesthetics of
whatever particular culture they are
trying to appeal to in order to make
money it is completely disingenuous and
whenever I see stuff like this I can't
help but get this Eerie feeling like the
corporation is some kind of evil entity
draping itself in human skin wearing a
human face trying to convince us that it
is like us when in reality it is just an
empty shell designed to acquire more and
more capital
the novel features a blending of
cultural elements from different regions
resulting in a hybridized and
superficially diverse World which on
some level seems like a perfectly fine
thing in perhaps even a good thing yet
beneath the surface there is a sense of
cultural loss that permeates this
narrative in fact the ai's wintermute
and Neuromancer exemplify this cultural
homogenization embodying emerging of two
disparate consciousnesses and erasing
individuality
the characters in the novel too often
find themselves estranged from their
cultural Roots existing in a globalized
world that commodifies and appropriates
cultural symbols I believe that Gibson's
portrayal of cultural homogenization
serves as a cautionary tale
urging us to preserve the uniqueness of
diverse cultures and identity in the
face of increasing globalization
part 4 the unending influence of
Neuromancer
one of the key contributions of
Neuromancer is the console Cowboy cyber
hacker archetype
case is a skilled computer hacker who
navigates through a vast network of
interconnected computers called the
internet excuse me called The Matrix
this concept of a protagonist with
exceptional computer skills operating a
world controlled by powerful
corporations became a staple of the
cyberpunk genre it set the stage for
Future Works where characters would
often explore virtual realities engage
in high-stakes hacking and challenge the
oppressive systems of the future it is
so common in fact that it is essentially
expected when it comes to the genre as I
mentioned earlier Gibson's novel also
introduced the concept of cyberspace his
depiction of a digital realm where
individuals could navigate and interact
with information directly influence the
portrayal of virtual reality in
subsequent cyberpunk works the idea of
jacking into a digital world and
experiencing alternate realities or
engaging in illicit activities Within
and cyberspace also became a common
Trope in the genre Neuromancer also
explores the themes of corporate
dominance and the vast wealth
disparities that would go on to define
the cyberpunk genre Mega corporations
held immense power and controlled every
aspect of society as we've mentioned
while the majority of people were left
struggling in poverty this depiction of
a bleak future shaped by corporate
control is also one of the largest
Hallmarks of cyberpunk Storytelling as
subsequent Works often portray dystopian
societies ruled by powerful corporations
with little regard for human physical
and mental welfare it cannot be
understated the crucial role that
Neuromancer played in solidifying
cyberpunk as a genre as I've gone over
the novel's Innovative Concepts like the
Cyber hacker cyberspace itself the
corporate dominance all laid the
foundation for the future of cyberpunk
before the release of neuromancers
cyberpunk as a distinct genre was still
in its infancy Gibson's novel cemented
cyberpunk among the sub-genres of
Science Fiction defining its key
characteristics
the book presented a dystopian vision of
the future where advanced technology and
a decaying Society intertwine its
narrative was marked by themes such as
artificial intelligence virtual reality
and the blurring boundaries between
humans and machines these tropes and
archetypes have endured and continue to
influence cyberpunk literature and also
films and video games ensuring the
legacy of Gibson as the father of the
cyberpunk genre
conclusion
in conclusion I really really really
love this book and I had never read it
before I asked for recommendations on
this channel just a few weeks ago and
once I read it I was entranced I put
everything else on hold to work on this
video I was fascinated to witness the
birth of so many tropes that have become
so commonplace in science fiction and
within cyberpunk specifically I plan on
covering the next two books in the
sprawl Trilogy count zero and Mona Lisa
Overdrive let me know if that's
something that you guys will be
interested in in the future thanks for
watching guys and make sure you like And
subscribe for more Quinn's ideas and if
you just can't get enough you can check
out my brand new podcast Cosmic
Chronicles WE Post episodes every other
Friday
[Music]
and now the time has come again for
patreon questions if you want to support
this channel you can help out by
donating through the PayPal Link in the
description or pledging on patreon
first question do you believe that
cyberpunk settings and fiction are an
inevitability or are they an exam of
humanity simply choosing to surrender to
self-destructive consumption also do you
think that reality has a cyberpunk
future well cyberpunk settings in
fiction most often depict a dystopian
future characterized by advanced
technology and societal Decay and the
dominance of powerful corporations and
while it's true that these narratives
often highlight the negative aspects of
technology and its impact on society I
don't think that they are necessarily an
examination of humanity choosing uh
self-destructive consumption cyberpunk
stories often explore themes such as
inequality and Corruption and the loss
of privacy and like I said that a
humanizing effects of a highly
technologized World they serve as a
cautionary tale a warning against the
potential day dangers of unchecked
technological progress and its unequal
distribution so I think more or less
it's a warning rather than this is
exactly what the future has to be now as
for whether I think reality will have a
cyberpunk future I think it's difficult
to predict with certainty while there
are some aspects of cyberpunk fiction
such as the increased surveillance and
corporate influence that can be seen in
our world today it's also important to
remember that science fiction often
exaggerates or amplifies certain
elements for dramatic effect I think
that the future is shaped by a very
complex and complicated interplay of
various factors and some of those
include political and social and
technological developments as mentioned
before and while certain Trends in our
current Society such as the rapid
advancement of technology and the
growing influence of Corporations do
raise very serious concerns I think that
the trajectory of our future is not
predetermined It ultimately depends on
the choices is we as a society make and
our ability to navigate the challenges
and opportunities presented by emerging
Technologies I I really think that it's
worth noting that many people are
actively working towards creating a more
Equitable and sustainable future and
technological advancements can also
bring about positive changes so while
elements of cyberpunk fiction may be
present in our reality I think it's up
to us ultimately to shape the future
that we want to see I'm trying to be
optimistic here next question from
Donovan Carr I am very familiar with
Gibson's work with recent advances in CG
do you think we could see Gibson's work
brought to the big screen in a way that
would honor the original work I.E like
the recent Alita battle Angel well I
have not seen a leader battle Angel but
the success of recent films like that
one which I've heard effectively
translated the intricate World building
and cyberpunk things from the original
manga
which I also haven't read kind of
demonstrates that it is indeed possible
to honor the essence of a beloved work
while leveraging the advancements in CGI
technology I also think that villeneo's
Dune is a great example of this as well
uh by carefully selecting a director and
a production team who deeply understand
and appreciate Gibson's writing it's
totally plausible to create a faithful
and immersive cinematic adaptation in my
opinion now of course adapting any
literary work to the big screen is a
complex Endeavor anyone that's saying
it's easy doesn't understand how much
work goes into filmmaking filmmakers
have to balance artistic interpretation
with capturing the essence of the
original story and that is not a simple
task however with the continuous
evolution of CGI capabilities we can
expect to see increasingly more
sophisticated visual representations of
Science Fiction worlds and Concepts and
I think we've already been seeing that
in recent years but this needs to be
combined with a dedicated creative team
committed to honoring Gibson's work and
I think that that could lead to an
adaptation that is both pleasing to fans
of the original work and also introduces
his work to a wider newer audience so
it's all about the people making it at
the end of the day next question I read
Neuromancer when it first came out and I
had my mind blown any thoughts on what
impact Neuromancer has on new readers
today is it still a good recommendation
for those new to cyberpunk well overall
I think Neuromancer is recommended
pretty often to readers still even to
this day as an essential work within the
cyberpunk genre while its technological
Concepts might feel somewhat dated to
some newer readers I think it's
compelling storytelling and
thought-provoking themes and its
enduring influence make it a valuable
and worthwhile read for anyone
interested in cyberpunk fiction in my
opinion when it comes to Classics like
these which are so influential by the
time a lot of people get around to
reading them they've already seen a
million things that have been inspired
by them so it doesn't have the same
effect personally I found Neuromancer to
be very compelling even though I've
definitely read and seen a lot of
Science Fiction that was heavily
inspired by it and I also think that
newer readers will be able to recognize
the parallels between the world of
Neuromancer in our own world because
there are many many similarities as
we've seen throughout the course of this
video
the final question how do you think the
theme of people being augmented by
technology particularly their minds has
changed over the decades as both
technology and our cultural relationship
to it has rapidly changed well I think
the ways that this has changed is well
as you know several decades ago this was
more of a fiction now we've moved into
the place where these concepts are
becoming very real people have started
to augment their bodies people have
started to augment their brains the
transhumanism movement is 100 happening
right now
people are installing microchips into
their bodies people are installing
antennas into their heads I think that
people younger than me and I am a young
millennial
are gonna be even more open to this sort
of physical augmentation because they
will have grown up in a world
that's unlike anything else seen before
in human history it's going to be
curious to see the development of
transhumanism and these sorts of
augmentations in the future for sure
all right and I think that's it for
patreon questions thanks so much for
listening guys
foreign
[Music]